[Applause]
thank you very much for being here my
pleasure this is all um it's a little uh
confusing to americans a dame
is the uh
is the female equivalent of a night is
that right it is and you may well say
what is a night but the night is is when
somebody is is knighted he's sir right
and his wife becomes lady right but then
the equivalent of a night for a woman is
dame and her husband my husband isn't
anything he's just michael there's no
well don't go around saying he isn't
anything
my husband's nothing
uh well right well what should he be you
don't want him being called lady nobody
like him difficult sir sir well why is
that that way it's just that's the way
it's always been that's the way it's
always been
mm-hmm well don't say that around the
palace and speaking of the palace do you
then you get to take part i would
imagine some pretty uh heady ceremonies
with no no no no that's nothing to do
with being a dame it absolutely does
nothing for you at all except that
people are very confused about what to
call you they don't know whether to call
you dame dench or sometimes lady right
and it's just dame judy and usually it's
julie
but you don't get anything you don't get
a cool scepter or you don't get a you
get a big badge you get a badge yes you
get a very sparkling badge when i went
to to to get it um i was with seven men
who were going to be made knights
and we were ushered into a room on our
own um and uh
the men were told that they
knelt down and they were dubbed with a
sword and i was told i'd gone to
enormous expense to have this dress made
beautifully tailored and the moment i
got in they put a kind of picture hook
thing on it which pulled it down on one
side um so that all and then they just
shove
this man was very nervous and said to
the sergeant-at-arms may i smoke and he
said no but you may play the piano he
said
but he didn't play this man
yeah he couldn't play the piano and he
was beheaded
it's
yeah
nice little story um what's about the
oscars for a moment uh i imagine that
that
not coming from not being from this
country even people in this country
freak out incredibly when they are
nominated for an oscar what was that
ceremony like you walked down the red
carpet and everyone's screaming your
name and
nobody's you know i thought the red
carpet was about this long i didn't know
nobody prepares you for the fact that
the red carpet is so long and what i now
know call the bleachers are beside you
and those people shouting um we had the
most incredible time i wouldn't have
missed it for anything but it was very
unreal indeed we were it was two days
and then suddenly i was back in a play
in london and it was as if i hadn't been
i'm curious the thing that i'm most
curious about in that ceremony is they
put the camera on all the people that
are up for the oscar
so i think there are is that right five
are there five people that are other
women that were up for the oscar and
they put the camera on all of them just
to see your reaction just to see your
reaction were you aware that a camera
was on you no i wasn't aware no i wasn't
tis cruel they do it in britain too
because you started screaming and
how dashing you've come all this way
you clawed someone's eyes out i remember
you do that you do certainly do that i
wish people would do that it would be
much more it would just be an honest
reaction you know if someone everyone's
always like oh i'm happy for the other
person they'll enjoy that award more
than happy together um
let's talk about this movie uh the
costumes in this movie are fantastic uh
you play
elizabeth the first elizabeth the first
we actually have a photo here from the
movie this is the costume frightening
this was just casual wear for her
this is just what you wear in an
afternoon yeah if she's painting the
ceiling that's what she'd put on what's
it like to get in and that looked like
it may have weighed 50 60 pounds easily
easily that what's that like how do you
get into that it takes you four hours to
get into it takes you over two hours to
get the makeup done do they lower you
into it are there i wish they had do
they fire the costume at you and it hits
you and you oh i'm in it i mean what how
does it work no it's just it's
stretched on you you know absolutely it
takes three people to to hold it carry
it
and then somehow you're into it and once
you're into it you can't get out i mean
you could die she could have died and
two weeks later she'd still be standing
there
they wouldn't know they would never know
especially with that white face you know
yeah they painted their faces white and
one of the things that's nice about this
movie is in a lot of these movies they
gloss over the fact that glamorize it
glamorize it and these people living in
the 1400s and the 1500s have these
beautiful sparkling wayne gretzky teeth
and uh what they what they gloss over is
that back then and they don't do that in
this movie people just had well i'm not
so sure i mean um you're a t-shirt every
rush and i come out rather badly in the
teeth stakes i think everyone else seems
to do rather well well what are they
doing it made me as sick as a parrot
when i saw the nurse saying to gwyneth
paltrow don't forget to do your teasing
she gave her a kind of stick to use
it's a pity that nobody thought of doing
that for me well what do they do to your
teeth to make them because they look
good they paint them they they gave me
prosthetics but they were so grotesque
that you know
from the cinema well we're thrilled you
could come by and uh yeah and and visit
us uh shakespeare in love opens two
weeks from today which is december 11th
and uh people should check out the movie
it's it's a great film dame judy dench
thank you for being here nice to have
you
we'll uh take a little break when we
come back elvis costello and bert
bacharach